Die Kategorie ist noch falsch, auf Twitch sehe ich gerade, ob es das jetzt gecheckt hat.
So, erstmal ausmachen, ich will mal nicht Werbung von meinem eigenen Zeug hat gucken.
Hat es?
Ja, hat es gecheckt.
Exzellent, exzellent.
Na, na, na, nice.
So, jetzt muss ich ein bisschen leiser machen, oder mal irgendwas anderes, irgendwas anderes.
Was ist das, das ist Mario Paint, alter, kennt das überhaupt noch jemand, das war ein super
Nintendo Game, wo du, wo du Musik machen konntest und Zeugs mal, also Mario Paint, da gab es
eine Maus für den Super Nintendo, Mario Paint, alter, ich erinnere mich noch dran, ich glaube
das Game hatte keine Speichermöglichkeiten, das war richtig, das war richtig fail.
Jaja, ich habe geswitcht, ich habe, die Kategorie war verkehrt.
Die Kategorie war falsch, ja Leute, gucken, was uns YouTube heute vorschlägt, 19 Monate
massive Subscriptions hier, exquisite, ist der Discord-Bot kaputt?
Guck mal, ich gucke mal kurz in Discord rein, ob der Discord-Bot kaputt, kam gerade, ok.
Jetzt gucken, Stream-Ankündigung, ja er hat es gecheckt, nicht so, ist nicht so schnell.
Ja, ist das schon der neue Gift-Player, Moment, Moment, Moment, Achtung, Achtung, nein, das
ist nicht der neue Gift-Player, der neue Gift-Player ist ja auch nicht wirklich in irgendeinem
Zustand, wo er funktioniert, das einzige, was der macht, ist aktuell Gifts furchtbar
schnell abspielen.
Twitch ist früher als Discord, ja ich weiß auch nicht, Discord-Bots sind in letzter Zeit
ein bisschen langsam, entweder hat Amazon übelst aufgerüstet oder Discord-Bots sind
langsamer geworden.
Moin, MRFLBR, 2 Monate, massive Subscriptions hier, so YouTube, letzte Chance, oh guck mal,
YouTube fliegt mir mal ein eigenes Video vor, exellent, erst mal, erst mal, erst mal die
Klicks kurz, kurz, generaten, ja, also YouTube, schlag mir mal was Gescheites vor, ich hab
schon ein paar Sachen offen, aber vielleicht gibt's ja, vielleicht gibt's ja noch mehr,
YouTube sagt, das soll ich unbedingt gucken, ok, exellent, ah, hier ist TypeScript, also
Javascript Magic ist mir heute einfach zu hoch.
Schneller kündigen und kürzere Laufzeit, achso, es geht um Handys, ich dachte ich könnte
jetzt einfach sagen, so Chef, morgen bin ich weg, will ich zwar nicht, aber wäre gut,
wenn man das machen könnte, ich weiß noch nicht, ob ich nachmittags weiter mache, ich
wollte mir eigentlich heute noch Dings angucken, Windows 11, Insider Build, das wirst du uns
eigentlich auch noch angucken, das sind immer so glückliche, was, was zum, was machen die
da überhaupt, achso, das soll Vater, Mutter im Bett sein und zwei Kinder am Start mit
Convertible Surface Dings, meine Güte, ey, wie sie immer so auf glückliche Familie machen
und irgendwelche Notebooks dafür in die Mitte stellen, ich glaube die Familie wäre am glücklichsten
ohne so ein fucking Notebook dabei, jetzt wird Windows drauf, aber ausgerechnet so sehen
Windows Insider aus, naja gut, wir wissen ja spätestens, dass, seit der Windows 11 Ankündigung
wissen wir ja, dass Leute im Krankenhaus, nachdem sie ein Kind zur Welt gebracht haben,
erstmal ein Teams Call machen mit der Oma, ich weiß du schaust es nicht, aber heute
Abend ist GDQ 21 Start, doch, ich guck wahrscheinlich ein bisschen rein, aber ich guck, ich guck
nicht mehr so viel, seit sie den Chat auf Sub-Only haben, also seit sie den Chat auf
Sub-Only haben und so mega korrekt sind mit allem, die haben ja beispielsweise schon Leute
ausgeladen, weil sie irgendwie einen blöden Witz gemacht haben über, über Fluggesellschaften
und sowas, ich kann es auch über echt übertreiben, oder Tri-Hacks haben sie letztens ausgeladen,
weil er irgendwas irgendwie, was Dummes mit seinen Freunden im Teamspeak gesagt hat und
so, also ich finde die übertreiben es, Windows Insider alle glückliche Großfamilien und
sicher nicht 14, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, Windows 11 User, gerade Windows Insider,
das hier sind die wahren Windows Insider, ja, wisst ihr was mich immer noch beeindruckt,
dass die ernsthaft, bist du krank, nee, das sagen alle immer Anfang am Stream, ich muss
immer erst mich warmreden, äh, wie die ernsthaft, was ist denn das für eine komische Border
um das Ding, das sieht da mega hässlich aus, what the fuck, naja gut, Microsoft Webdesign,
weiß nie so genau, was wollte ich jetzt sagen, ich finde es immer noch beeindruckend, dass
die ernsthaft mit Windows in der Mitte werben, ich finde diesen Windows Knopf in der Mitte
ist so extrem unergonomisch, also mir ist es egal, ich drücke eh die Windows Taste,
aber manchmal, manchmal drücke ich es auch von Hand, und links unten die Windows Taste
ist total easy, weil du haust einfach deine Maus unten links hin und klickst, das kannst
du hier jetzt nicht machen, also wer ernsthaft auf die Idee gekommen ist, dass der Button
in der Mitte irgendwie ergonomischer ist, der hat echt den Schuss da mal gehört, ja, man
kann es umstellen, aber das Problem ist, dass es Default ist, warum macht man Sachen die
unergonomischer sind Default, man kann in Windows nahezu alles irgendwie an irgendeiner Art
umstellen, sei es nur mit irgendwelchen Oldschool Registry Hacks oder sowas, aber ich verstehe
den Sinn davon nicht, warum man etwas unergonomischeres als Default macht, ich verstehe, dass sie
sagen, hey, es ist präsenter in der Mitte vom Bildschirm, wenn man dieses Menü macht,
es spricht ja nichts dagegen, dass man das Menü in die Mitte machen würde, selbst wenn
man links hin klickt, da macht man das Menü halt so fett, dann ist es doch eigentlich
egal, oder man macht die Gnome 3 Geschichte, dass halt das Startmenü einfach so aufgeht,
ach, was auch immer, ja warum ist ein Startknopf links nicht für Tablets zu benutzen, das hat
ja mit der Plattform nichts zu tun, außerdem sind die meisten User garantiert keine Tablet-User
mit Windows, also sprich, also nochmal, warum macht man etwas unergonomischeres was 80%
der Benutzer betrifft Default und macht nicht einfach einen If, wenn man es wirklich für
ergonomischer in der Mitte hält, einfach einen If, sagt, ey, wenn es ein Tablet ist,
dann ist es halt in der Mitte, meinetwegen, also ich kann die Microsoft-Logik da immer
noch nicht ganz nachvollziehen, wobei ich es auch nicht wirklich extrem schlimm finde,
Hauptsache der Kram funktioniert, und ich hoffe die Windows-Suche funktioniert mal irgendwie,
weil, naja, File Search ist halt komplett broken, KekW, was findet der Mensch nach KekW-Suche,
Dungeon-Keeper-Gold, exzellent, äh, sagt, sagt, und warum ist sogar die Windows, warum
ist die Windows-Seite einfach kaputt, guck mal, die Windows-Seite ist einfach broken
im Chrome, die meisten lassen es so wie es ist, ja das ist ja genau der Punkt, warum
es unsinnig ist, was uneconomischer ist als Default zu machen, dann nervt es die meisten
Leute, ohne dass sie wissen, dass es sie richtig nervt, die sind einfach nur unzufrieden und
wissen nicht genau, woran es liegt, es ist einfach bescheuert sowas, Default zu machen,
der einzige Grund ist, dass man weniger Erneuerungen als mehr Erneuerungen verkaufen kann, das
ist der einzige Grund, warum die so ein Scheiß machen, oh Leute, wenn ich die Musik höre,
welcher Spruch muss jetzt im Chat kommen, ihr wisst es genau, gucken ob es der Chat weiß,
ich bin mir nicht so sicher, der Chat weiß es nicht, fast richtig, fast richtig, so, äh,
das, das, das verstehe ich nicht, Windows ist nur ein Spielelauncher, naja, viele Leute
verwenden Windows für alles mögliche, es gibt sogar Leute, die programmieren Sachen
unter Windows, ich kann es zwar auch nicht verstehen, außer es ist Windows Only, aber
das gibt es, aber soll jeder machen wie er will, ja also YouTube ist nicht in der Lage
mir gerade gescheite Sachen zu empfehlen, ich meine ich habe hier schon genug Sachen
offen, ja Windows Server ist eh das Schlimmste, wisst ihr was ich geil finde, dass Leute,
die, ich kann jetzt natürlich nicht allgemein sprechen für alle, aber wisst ihr was meine
Erfahrung mit Windows Admins ist, dass die auch keine Ahnung haben, was sie eigentlich
machen, gerade bei uns ist es immer so, wenn es irgendwelche Berechtigungsfehler gibt,
auf irgendwas nicht zugreifen kannst, dann liegt es in der Regel immer daran, dass einem
irgendwelche Active Directory Berechtigungen fehlen, so, dann gehst du zu den Leuten bei
uns, die Active Directory machen und dann sagst du, ja ich kann keine Ahnung, denken wir uns
jetzt mal was aus, ich kann aufs Ticket System nicht zugreifen, äh, ich glaube das liegt
an Active Directory Berechtigungen, könnt ihr mir das einrichten und dann fragen die
dich ernsthaft, ja welche Gruppe soll ich hinzufügen, dann sag ich keine Ahnung, die
Gruppe, die dafür zuständig ist, dass man eben Ticket System Berechtigungen hat, ja
wie heißt denn die Gruppe, ja das weiß ich nicht, das ist so ein Henne-Eye Problem, wisst
ihr, du kannst auf was nicht zugreifen sollst, aber wissen wie die Active Directory Gruppe
heißt, für das wo du keine Rechte drauf hast, so, was bei dir für eine Web Application
läuft, das wo ich hier Overlays anzeige, und, was, der Breathing PC ist geil, ok, jetzt
können wir uns gleich, gleich dann mal angucken, wenn das, wenn das nice ist, oh nee, 18 Minuten,
da muss ich, da muss ich wieder vor skippen, so, und, das wollte ich jetzt sagen, genau,
und das wird ja dann, das wird dann immer noch besser mit der Zeit, dann nervst du
weiter herum, sagst du, keine Ahnung, ich weiß nicht welche Berechtigungen fürs Ticket
System zuständig sind, so und dann sagen sie, welcher User hat denn, hat dann noch,
hat dann auch noch Berechtigungen und wir haben uns letztens mal den Spaß gemacht, der
Felix und ich, wir hatten, also ich durfte auf das Ticket, oder ich sag jetzt einfach
mal Ticket System, ich durfte auf das Ticket System zugreifen und der Felix durfte nicht
auf das Ticket System zugreifen, da haben wir uns letztens mal den Spaß gemacht und
haben mit irgendeinem, ich weiß nicht mal was es war, mit irgendeinem PowerShell Kommando
ausgelesen, in welchen AD Gruppen er ist und in welchen AD Gruppen ich bin und wir sind
zu dem Schluss gekommen, wir sind beide in über, passt mal auf, haltet euch fest, in über
300 Gruppen, in über 300 Gruppen und irgendwie in 80 unterschiedlichen Gruppen, eine von
diesen 80 unterschiedlichen Gruppen ist das Ticket, ist die Ticket System Berechtigung.
Ja, so und jetzt kommt der Hit, und jetzt kommt, und jetzt kommt der Hit, daraufhin hatten
sie keine Ahnung, welche das ist und was haben sie gemacht, sie haben den User vom Felix
neu erstellt und haben ihn geklont aus meinem User mit den Berechtigungen, jetzt fehlen
ihm wahrscheinlich Berechtigungen für alles andere, das ist so, also meine Erfahrung ist
Windows Admins haben auch absolut keinen Plan von dem was sie machen.
Gebe es Twitch, dankeschön für den Prime Sub, ActiveDirect ist PaintsChamp, ja ist
es, generell diese Microsoft Server Welt, alles was nicht, wobei selbst Microsoft hier
Client Welt Windows, Windows Technik ist PaintsChamp, ist die Musik ein bisschen lauter, was ist
denn der Everybody Votes Channel, hat jemand dokumentiert bei euch, das glaubst du doch
selbst nicht, dass das irgendwo steht, die ganzen AD Gruppen haben irgendeinen Comment
dran, aber das ist, ich hab das, ich hab das doch sogar mal, ich hab das doch sogar mal
auf Twitter gepostet, so einen kleinen Auszug von, ein bisschen anonymisiert, unsere Gruppennamen
sind so unglaublich wir, die heißen dann sowas wie, keine Ahnung, Test, DP, Underscore,
Old, Underscore, Notes, Underscore, IT, Underscore, Admin, keine Ahnung, da sind dann solche,
da sind dann solche langen Gruppen oder so, da blickt echt keiner mehr durch, ja, so,
es gibt YouTube keine Videos, die irgendwie wir uns auch zuletzt nicht angucken sollen,
ok, exellent, AD Stream, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, also das werd ich mir nicht
geben Leute, also wir machen garantiert kein Active Directory Stream, also bevor ich jemals
in die Windows Server Welt gehe, dann wechsle ich den Job, das mach ich nicht, ja, schießlo,
aber nur wenn der Chat mitmachen darf, ja, mach mal, genau, ungefähr so sehen unsere
Benutzergruppen aus, das ist dynamisch gewachsen, ja, das ist bei uns auch immer die Aussage,
wobei wir sagen nicht dynamisch gewachsen, sondern wir sagen meistens, das ist historisch
gewachsen, das ist in Base64, mal, Decoder, guck mal mal, ist alles Tosssafe, na, ich glaub
dir mal, Decode, what the fuck, das sieht nicht Tosssafe aus, ich weiß nicht was das für
einen komisch, das sieht immer noch ein bisschen verschlüsselt aus, keine Ahnung was das ist,
da braucht man wahrscheinlich einen Tor Browser um das aufzumachen oder so, ey Max, weißt
du ob die MikroTek Switch, ja, also ob es die reinen Switche mit SwitchOS können, glaub
ich nicht, aber die RouterOS sollten es eigentlich können, aber wirklich benutzt hab ich das
noch nicht bei MikroTek, aber das können, also die RouterOS Dinger können das, ist
das Rot13 oder so, komm wir probieren das jetzt nochmal aus, ok, also, sagen wir mal
ob wir dahinter kommen, so, dann brauchen wir das, RotDecoder, gibt es ja alles als irgendwie,
ja der Thomas Kuhn, der nicht verschlüsselt, ich will es entschlüsselt haben, äh, das
schenke ich nicht, ah hier, harte TPS, ok, die Seite mache ich nicht auf, die Seite mache
ich auf der zweiten Website auf, ok, naja, gut, wir haben es raus gekriegt, exzellent,
oder ist auf der Website noch irgendwas, was man finden kann im Source Code, das war jetzt
der erste Schritt, ok, ja, das waren wir jetzt aber nicht im Stream, aber ist eine interessante
Idee, da muss man sich den Website in Source Code jetzt irgendwie nochmal angucken, ok,
fangen wir mal an, was gucken wir uns an, YouTube letzte Chance, ok, Battlefield 4, 34 Sekunden,
das ist bestimmt TOS Musik, da kommen jetzt 50 Leute raus oder so, ja ok und weiter, noobs,
alles, alles noobs, weiß doch jeder, man hätte die Defi killen müssen, nicht, nicht einfach
drauf schießen, den disrespect Defi Kill machen, ich hätte die alle entweder Defi
Kill oder Repair Tool Kill, easy, gar kein Problem, gut, YouTube kann uns nichts geschadet
und empfehlen uns nichts gescheites, also da würde ich sagen, dann lassen wir uns mal
wieder, wir lassen uns mal eine Runde von LevelCaptureBaden, jedesmal und da kann ich
jedesmal sagen, Alter, was der wieder daraus macht, weiß doch eh schon jeder, noch nicht
das neue Alpha 4 Games Video geschaut, doch, das habe ich gestern geschaut, aber das fand
ich jetzt nicht so spannend, weil gerade das Spielgenre ist, was mich eh null juckt,
ich finde das immer so geil, der Titel ist so am Anfang New Battlefield Gameplay Details
und jetzt sagt er so, we might get New Battlefield Gameplay Details, das ist immer der gleiche
Kram, eh übrigens, übrigens, ja, ja, es gibt, also ich kann nicht, also ich hab mich
mal wieder verpflichtet, nichts zu sagen, ja, ja, es gibt neue Details, das ist korrekt.
Ja, gut, wenn sie genug Geld bezahlen, warum nicht, ne?
Hause-Cham!
Ja, denn ich finde das eh total langweilig, aktuell, mit 2042, ja, es arbeiten sich alle
an den gleichen Details ab und keiner hat es jemals in Action gesehen, ich hab mir auch
überlegt, ob ich noch ein zweites Video drüber machen soll, zum Beispiel, was ich gerade
sehr, sehr merkwürdig finde, ist, dass sich so viele Leute über die neuen Operator, die
nicht Operator, sondern Specialist heißen, also diese Custom Klassen, dass sich gerade
so viele Leute darüber aufregen, was Battlefield 2042 ausgeht, verstehe ich nicht, weil eigentlich
ändert sich überhaupt nichts, also der Unterschied ist nur, dass eh früher die Klassen frei customizable
waren, jetzt pickst du einen Operator und customisest den, also wisst ihr, wie ich meine, du konntest
früher, hast du den Medic ausgewählt und hast dann customisest, ob du nen Defi mitnimmst
oder ob du nen, nee, Smoke, doch, ob du Smoke mitnimmst, ob du eh ne Shotgun mitnimmst
oder was auch immer, also du hast deine Base Class ausgewählt und die hast du customisest,
so, jetzt, jetzt wählst du den Operator aus und customisest den, das macht doch überhaupt
keinen Unterschied, also sprich, ob ich jetzt nen Medic auswähle, Medipack, Defi nehme,
ob ich jetzt nen Medic aus, Assault, Sturmsoldat auswähle, Medipack, Defi nehme, ob ich jetzt
nen Sturmsoldat auswähle, Smoke, Granate und Medipack nehme, macht überhaupt keinen
Unterschied, in Battlefield 2042 wärs dann halt so, um jetzt mal das gleiche Beispiel
zu nehmen, ich nehm den Operator mit dem Defi und rüste den mit nem Medipack aus oder ich
nehm den Operator mit dem Smoke Granatenwerfer und geb dem nen, ne, ne Heel, nen Medipack,
also rein von der Mechanik her, ist das genau das gleiche wie Customizable Base Classen,
aber irgendwie weiß ich nicht, warum man sich da so drüber aufregt, der einzige Unterschied
ist, es ist viel geiler zu monetarisieren von EA, also für die ist das gut, ne, also
wenn du nur 4 Klassen hast, ist natürlich kacke, die kannst du zwar auch Skins anbieten
und sonst was, aber wenn du 10 Operator hast, da kannst du Skins mal 10 anbieten, ist natürlich
viel nicer, ne, also du kannst das besser monetarisieren, für die ist das gut, gameplay
technisch macht das glaub ich überhaupt keinen Unterschied, ob es Customizable Base Classen
sind oder ob es Customizable Operator sind mit einem festen Gadget, es macht in der Ausrüstung
her überhaupt keinen Unterschied, das was viel größeren Unterschied macht beim neuen
Battlefield ist, dass du jetzt jede Waffe mit jeder Klasse ausrüsten kannst, das hat
damit den Operators nichts zu tun, da bin ich ja persönlich auch noch skeptisch, weil
das wird dafür sorgen, dass es wieder, dass es so ein ähnliches Meta gibt wie in Warzone,
dass 2-3 Waffen geil sind und der Rest spielt keiner mehr, in den anderen Battlefield Teilen
war es immerhin so, dass es quasi, sag mal so, so eine Best oder dass es so 3 richtig
gute Waffen Assault gibt, 3 richtig gute Waffen Sniper, 3 richtig gute Waffen Engineer und
sowas, das wird jetzt nicht mehr so sein, wenn jeder alles ausrüsten kann und sagen
wir mal, ein Engineer Operator auch keinen Bonus bekommt auf Submachine Guns oder so,
dann werden alle mit dem gleichen OP Assault Rifle rumrennen und alle mit der gleichen
OP Sniper rumrennen, das ist das was ich jetzt eher doof finde, das ist aber nicht das Problem
von den Operator, sondern die generelle Entscheidung, zumal man jetzt sogar noch einen Ticken weiter
geht und sagt, man kann die Waffen Customize, während man im Spiel ist, also ich kann das
Scope zu einem Red Dot tauschen mit meiner Semi Auto Sniper, je nachdem wo ich unterwegs
bin, das ist natürlich schon ein anderer Punkt, weil so im Haus mit einem fetten Scope,
ja, ne, auf der Konsole kein Problem, gerade auf der Xbox 360 damals mit Auto, ne, aber
keine Ahnung, das ist eher das Problem finde ich, wann kommen die neuen Videos, wir haben
noch nichts aufgenommen, wir nehmen wahrscheinlich auch wieder erst was aus, was wirklich substanzielle
Neuigkeiten gibt, blablabla, Alter, das macht mich immer fertig, das Handy vibriere bei Levelcap,
ja, was zum Teufel hat ein Festplattenhersteller mit Battlefield zu tun, das hätte ja besser
zu Modern Warfare gepasst, BD Black, Bravo 6, ne, wie hießen die, Alpha 6, ne, Bravo
6 hießen die oder, ach, ich hab schon wieder vergessen, die Modern Warfare Typ, ja, ich
weiß nicht wann die Beta startet, ich weiß nicht wann die Beta startet, ich warte die
ganze Zeit auch schon drauf, weil die haben zu uns gesagt, es gibt ein Play-Testing, eventuell
sogar ein internal Play-Testing-Test, wo man daran teilnehmen kann, das sollte angeblich
jetzt irgendwann kommen, aber ich hab davor noch nix gehört von EA, also, ist natürlich
doof, ich würd's gern mal spielen, ja, und außerdem ist Warzone mittlerweile 500G oder
so groß, da hätten sie einen Festplattenpartner brauchen können.
Ich hoffe man darf freestreamen, ja, das reicht ja auch, 40 Minuten Inhalt ist auf jeden Fall
besser als 40 Minuten sinnloses Kreisgelaber, guckt euch mal die, äh, äh, äh, äh, guckt
euch mal die eineinhalb Stunden an, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh,
äh, äh, guckt euch mal die eineinhalb Stunden Windows Präsentation an.
Das war einfach nur 3-1 1,5 Stunden sinnlosen Gelaber.
Nehm mir das lieber, die zeigen 40 Minuten was und gut ist, äh, wann kommt eigentlich
face reveal ja bei einer millionen abos
reddit und social media
they've confirmed 2042's movement system builds
on top of battlefield vives
ja und
however the developer that
disched that info later clarified he was talking
about
ist das trinity aus der
matrix
die bildauflösung ist so schlecht
ja
man erkennt das kaum
macht ihr mal
das hat jetzt nichts mit da zu tun wahrscheinlich
erstmal skippen
der hat es jetzt geschafft
hier wirklich dreieinhalb minuten news drüber zu machen
ohne irgendwas zu sagen
das ist wirklich absolut next level
da kann ich mir was von abgucken
und uns sehr laut gemacht
zwischendurch
genau schön 10 minuten 11 sekunden lang
was ok was schreibe bioware
ach bioware
leute ich muss euch ehrlich was sagen
wenn ich sowas lese also ich hab ja
ein bisschen meine mein vertrauen in
bioware verloren
man man man sieht das einfach das
letzte richtig was war das letzte
richtig gute bioware game dragon age
wobei ich sagen muss hey selbst schon das
original dragon age
hat mir nicht mehr so gut gefallen wie die
davor
aber das original dragon age war
schon noch ziemlich pock
wobei ich sagen muss dass gerade das kampf
system im original dragon age war
irgendwie schwammig
das war so eine mischung aus wir wollen es
konsolen gerecht machen wir wollen es aber doch
pc gerecht machen aber
NPCs
character verhalten sich manchmal
nicht was ich gesagt habe
und manchmal machen sie selbst
ganz merkwürdig also
das original dragon age war schon cool
aber ich muss schon sagen ich finde
original dragon age und sagen wir so
mess effect wenn man die games mag
ja die waren sicherlich auch nicht verkehrt
aber
spätestens ab dragon age 2 war vorbei
ja da habe ich gestern
das video das können wir uns übrigens auch nochmal angucken
da habe ich gestern das video zugesehen
es sind irgendwelche leute die haben sich
eine endgame
battlefield 3 endgame dlc map
rausgesucht haben die ein bisschen umgebaut
und wollen da jetzt einen battle royale drauf
entwickeln ich bin ich
kenne mich ja
ich bin skeptisch was das ganze
angeht weil es ist wieder so ein
typischer mod die basics
sind immer easy zu programmieren
also die basics von einem battle royale
die würde wahrscheinlich also ich habe absolut keine
ahnung von spiele entwicklung
aber würde mir jemand
eine engine mit ordentlichen tools und schon erfertigen
map in die hand drücken
die basics von so einem battle royale
ein flugzeug fliegt drüber spawned leute
und du setzt
random nen circle der immer sich halbiert
und kleiner random über die map wandelt
also die basics die könnte ich wahrscheinlich
auch in zwei drei tagen programmieren obwohl ich keine
ahnung von spiele programmierung habe
das komplexe
liegt sicherlich im detaille
deswegen bin ich immer skeptisch
bei so community mods die sehen
am anfang immer super promising aus
weil du halt schnelle große schritte machen
kannst und es sieht halt cool aus und es passiert
sich viel aber die
verlaufen sich dann oftmals nach
paar monaten entwicklung weil sie feststellen
fuck im detail ist es ja doch nicht so
einfach ja zum beispiel möchten
die battlefield das habe ich gesehen das wir gucken uns
warte mal wir gucken wir gucken uns mal kurz das video an
dann kann ich mal meinen senf zu geben weil ich finde es
sogar ein gewisses potenzial
wenn tatsächlich
battlefield 2042 kein
battle royale haben sollte
...
Das ist was, ich weiß nicht wie gut die Modding Tools für Venice sind aktuell, kann ich nicht
einschätzen, aber wenn man schon eine mehr oder weniger fertige Map hat, so eine Flugzeug-Sache
zu scripten und einen Circle zu bauen, das ist nicht schwer.
Sie haben so ein Ping-System eingebaut, was halt äußerst rudimentär und basic aussieht,
aber sie wollen zum Beispiel auch Inventar-Management und sowas einbauen und da fängt es an kompliziert
zu werden.
Da musst du viel darauf achten, wie so die Interaction ist, dass du nicht aus Versehen
Waffen vervielfältigen kannst und sowas, da musst du halt auch gucken, dass du das
ordentlich bugfrei programmierst.
Das ist im Detail dann schon wieder gar nicht mehr so einfach, deswegen habe ich immer
das Gefühl, dass solche Community-Mods sich oftmals totlaufen, die ersten 2-3 Monate
ultra gehypt, alle sind dabei, viel Progress gemacht, aber das richtig komplizierte, das
wird dann nie fertig.
Fantastic!
The Mod will feature a heavily modified and expanded map, a Circle of Deaths similar to
Firestorms, a custom dropship Ping-System and an in-depth loot system that lets you customize
individual attachments.
There's no ETA for the Mod's launch, but playtesting should start in the next couple of months.
Der Mod, der kommt wahrscheinlich vor 2 Jahren oder so nicht raus, die haben ja auch gesagt,
dass dieunciproc truth dot com sorgfältig handeln wherever und in changer literate
Mods mest zu spielen.
Die sensibilistische Samsung Project Being so butterball, ist eigentlich gar nicht
Cancelable.
Derield Connector war nur nochconfidence successfully installed in requires for real
time survival.
in den nächsten wenigen Monaten.
Cheaters in Call of Duty Warzone sind kein neues Problem,
aber die Schwierigkeit der Explosionen, die sie benutzen,
wird nur schlimmer.
Neue Cheat-Programme...
Ja, Ravensoft ist ja auch total unfähig.
... haben gehofft, dass die Spieler ihre Waffen
auf den Boden schießen lassen und immer noch
Gegner schießen lassen.
Dieser Style der Cheat ist sehr populär
seitdem.
Es heißt Silent Aim und es ist
viel einfacher als normale Aim-Bots zu benutzen.
Es gibt auch Cheats, die Spieler in
der Lobby aus dem Spiel verbreiten können,
Ravensoft ist so unfähig.
All this is happening
despite Raven banning
tens of thousands of players every month.
Leute, habe ich das nicht
genau das letzte Woche gesagt?
Wenn die alle paar Monate
paar tausend Spieler bannen, ist das
einfach nichts. Das ist einfach ein Tropfen
auf'n heißen Stein, die machen sich neue
Accounten gut ist.
Und selbst wenn.
Das ist ja eh nur ein Bruchteil,
von dem dies betrifft.
Und Ban-Waves
machen eine Schnauze
in dem Problem, aber es ist wirklich wie
Wack-A-Mole auf einer Maschine, die nie
stoppt. Es gibt keine Ahnung, wie schlecht
Dinge wir bekommen, wenn Raven sie nicht
unter Kontrolle bekommen kann.
Death Stranding und Metal Gear Solid-Kreator
Hideo Kojima arbeitet auf ein Verhältnis
mit Microsoft, um sein nächstes Spiel zu
publizieren. Kojima hat eine Schrift
von Intent zwischen Microsoft und
selbst bezeichnet. Das ist der erste Schritt
zu dem Deal.
Sony publizierte Death Stranding und
hat auch die Maschine für das Spiel getroffen.
Es war eine große Investition für
ihre PlayStation-Brande und es hat
deutlich gekämpft, weil das Spiel ein
großer Erfolg war.
Das nächste Spiel wird
ein Xbox-Exklusiv,
obwohl es sicherlich auf PC sein wird.
Das letzte Update für
Elite Dangerous
könnte als
das größte Update
sein.
Und
wenn ich
irgendwas 2D-mäßiges machen würde,
vielleicht auch irgendwas ganz anderes.
Keine Ahnung, aber ich habe von Spielentwicklung
keinen Plan.
Warum nicht Crytek?
CryEngine
nein, auf gar keinen Fall.
Was ist, ich glaube CryEngine
ist auch C++, aber
weil ich mir da gar nicht sicher bin, aber soll
dokumentationstechnisch und tutorial-
und materialmäßig absolut schlecht und
eklig sein.
Hat schon einen Grund, warum Star Citizen nicht
rauskommt.
Und es hat einen Grund, warum es
CryEngine heißt.
Was macht
Star Citizen eigentlich so, wenn ich das gerade sehe?
Das ist ja nicht Star Citizen, das ist Elite Dangerous,
aber was macht Star Citizen aktuell
eigentlich so?
Mobile Games!
Ne, das ist ja kein Mobile Games.
Natürlich, was sonst?
Ja, was meint ihr denn, warum nicht den Laden gekauft haben?
Sicherlich nicht, um
krass wohltätig zu sein.
Hä?
Du wolltest grad sagen, das ist doch wie bei Dark Souls.
Was genau
hatte Corona damit zu tun jetzt?
Ich hab mittlerweile das Gefühl,
Corona ist die Standardantwort für alles.
So nach dem Motto, ja warum macht ihr
jetzt auf einmal B, obwohl ihr
gesagt habt ihr macht A?
Corona.
Das gibt doch gerade keinen Sinn.
Ich bin heute Morgen übrigens
nach dem Aufstehen nicht aufs Klo gegangen, warum?
Corona.
Moment, ist das Puppe?
Ist das Puppe?
Moment, ist das Puppe
oder ist das H1Z?
Ne, das ist Puppe.
Wisst ihr, was mich ein bisschen ärgert?
Am Microsoft
Flight Simulator,
dass es noch kein Frankfurter
Main gibt,
was realistisch nach Frankfurter
Main aussieht. Ich muss sagen, das ist eines der
größten Flugzeuge und
wichtigsten Gebiete der
Welt, aber Flug Simulator
hat gedacht, ne,
die haben
ein generiertes
Frankfurter Main Stadtgebiet aus
Microsoft Karten
oder
Bing Maps heißt es ja glaube ich,
aber das sieht halt, wenn du drüber fliegst,
nur sehr am
Rande nach Frankfurter Main aus.
Du hast ein paar Gebäude, die
erkennst du wieder, aber beispielsweise da,
wo der Main Tower
steht, steht ein
großer, schwarzer
Skyscraper, was heißt das auf Deutsch?
Hochhaus, Wolkenkratzer
und kein
Main Tower und sowas, es ist
fail, ja.
Ja, ich weiß, es gibt den Frankfurter
Flughafen als Download, das weiß ich, aber ich
red ja von der
Stadt.
Da weiß ich nicht, ob es das als Download gibt.
Zumindest im Original Base Game
sieht Frankfurter Stadtgebiet halt
nur äußerst entfernt
nach Frankfurt aus. Was stimmt,
ist der Main und die Brücke drüber, das können
sich ja gut aus Bing Maps sich rausziehen,
aber die ganze Gebäudeplatzierung
und auch die Interpretation
der Hochhäuser,
das
Flug Simulator Algorithmus, was das eben aus
Bing Maps macht, hat mit der Realität
nicht allzu viel zu tun.
Warum nur den Frankfurter? Weil mich der Leipziger
Flughafen nicht interessiert.
In Leipzig haben die mein DHL-Paket
glaub drei Wochen
nicht auf die Reihe bekommen. Die kriegen
kein Flug Simulator Update. Frankfurt ist mir
ein wichtiger.
Ja, ja, ja.
Level Cap GBA.
Ist das ein Toaster?
Nee.
Also wenn ich das ehe,
also wenn ich quasi
einen Cartridge-Slot habe
und original Games brauche, die ich
dann emuliert spiele,
das ist ja wahrscheinlich
eh schon so eine Grauzone,
dann kann ich mir wahrscheinlich auch
gleich irgendwo den ROM runterladen,
wenn ich das original spiele,
dann genauso Grauzone.
Bald wieder IT-Media, da brauche ich ein paar Themen für.
By the way, ich hoffe,
ich hoffe, das ist ja das Gameplay, was wir schon gesehen haben,
ich hoffe, dass es im Original
ein bisschen, warte mal,
lass mal hier hin, dass es im Original
alles ein bisschen klarer und weniger
blurry ist. Guckt euch das mal an.
Du erkennst ja absolut gar nichts.
Hätten die hier nicht grüne Namen über
den Leuten, du würdest dir nicht, du würdest,
würdest du dir den erkennen? Ich würde nichts
erkennen.
Also ich hoffe, dass es dann weniger,
dass es jetzt halt cinematic ist, aber weniger
blurry und weniger, weniger
äh, wir
alles, ja.
Das ist eine Grauzone.
ROMs sind allgemeine
Grauzone.
Also überhaupt
sind solche Dinger immer
schwierig, ja.
Ja, GTA ist
Resident Sleeper.
Der cartridge slot spielt ja
nicht die Spiele.
Der cartridge slot ist quasi
ein Lesegerät. Was die Spiele
spielt, ist ein ganz normaler Emulator.
Und ob
inwieweit da nicht irgendwelche Rechte
verletzt werden oder sonst was,
ich glaube, das kannst weder du noch ich
als klar Ja oder Nein beantworten.
Deswegen sage ich ja Grauzone.
Ja, GTA 5 ist
eines der größten
quasi
Money macht Dinger
aller Zeiten.
Stimmt, was macht eigentlich Elder Scrolls 6?
Hat man da von irgendwas gehört
in letzter Zeit? Nee, oder? Glaub nicht.
Gab's dazu irgendwas bei der E3
vielleicht? Elder Scrolls
6.
Vor 20 Stunden, oder was? Okay, Ted
Howard, ja gut, 20 times the
detail oder wieviel waren 16 times
the detail oder ach, was auch immer.
Also was Todd erzählt,
sollte ja nun mittlerweile niemand mehr glauben.
Ich meine, die haben es ganz schön
verkackt. Skyrim kam
2013 oder
so.
2011,
Alter kam das schon.
Das ist 10 Jahre alt. Die haben es, guck mal,
Skyrim war übelst erfolgreich.
Und die haben es innerhalb von 10
Jahren, sieht man mal, dass bei denen
überhaupt keiner mehr irgendwie fähige Leute hat.
Die haben es bei so einem
mega erfolgreichen Game
nicht geschafft,
in 10
Jahren
irgendwas Vorzeigbares zu machen.
Sie haben ein komisches Mobile
Elder Scrolls gemacht,
was sagt?
Nee, also
die sind, glaube ich,
nicht mehr in der Lage,
noch was zu machen.
Okay, also was gucken wir uns jetzt
als nächstes an?
Das ist bestimmt Residence Leaper.
Okay, wir lassen uns
mal nicht...
Was ist das? Okay, Moment, das müssen wir uns jetzt anschauen.
Aber ich skippe, ich skippe
die langweiligen Parts, sag ich euch gleich.
Elder Scrolls 6
wird mittlerweile für 2027,
2028 geschätzt. Wer schätzt denn
sowas?
Warte,
warum?
Aber wieso?
Ach, ist das,
ist das, hä? Aber
okay, okay, man muss nicht
immer hinterfragen, warum.
Ah, gerade beim Mittagessen kann ich auch viel
mehr mir schiffen, gar kein Problem.
Ich habe einmal
in einem Video von ihm geguckt,
und ich fand das Ergebnis nicht
sonderlich praktikabel und ansprechend.
Mal gucken, wie das diesmal ist.
Ich skippe wahrscheinlich, ja, okay.
Aha, ich dachte, jetzt kann ich gleich skippen,
aber das war Jebait, das war,
das war Skip, Skip Jebait
gerade.
Dem mit praktikabel bei dem letzten Video
meine ich nicht, dass es
praktikabel zu bauen ist oder nicht,
das ist ja,
das war auch nicht praktikabel zu bauen,
aber das war mir egal. Die Benutzung des
Endprodukts fand ich unpraktikabel,
so mit diesen komischen
Klappen, die du rausfahren
musstest, dass du ans Laufwerk
kommst und sowas.
Viel einfacher wäre es eigentlich,
sich auf Fiverr irgendeinen Inder zu kaufen,
der für ein permanentes Holz bewegt.
Das kostet auf Fiverr.
Ich habe auf Fiverr geguckt, es gibt auf
Fiverr Angebote, I do everything
und geht ab 5 Dollar los.
Da kannst du dir auch jemand holen,
der dein Brett bewegt im Rechner
die ganze Zeit.
Alles kein Problem.
Oder ich kaufe mir
zwei Leute, die pusten
die ganze Zeit abwechselnd.
Das geht natürlich auch.
Weiß jemand,
wieso die,
wie nennt man das,
der Luftdurchsatz quasi ist,
zwischen pusten und einen modernen
High-End PC Lüfter?
Also kann man soviel
pusten für kurze Zeit
wie einen PC Lüfter lüften?
Ich weiß nicht, in welcher
Einheit das gemessen wird,
noch in welchem Druck
oder wie auch immer.
Kann man nicht.
Na gut.
Lungenvolumen liegt bei 6 Liter?
Na gut, die Frage ist, wie schnell
kriegst du die 6 Liter rausgepustet?
Egal.
Nachbar, meint ihr,
der macht die Dinger wirklich selbst?
Oder er hat seine
Leute, die das Zeug für ihn machen
und er baut die dann nur im Video zusammen?
Noctur 120mm Lüfter
macht 100...
Was?
Kubikmeter pro Stunde?
Klingt schon, klingt irgendwie viel.
Der kann sich fast eine Luftmatratze mit aufpumpen.
Ah, yes.
Naja, das Problem ist,
dass er ein Loch in der Wand hat.
Moment, Moment.
Was hat das jetzt mit Wasser zu tun?
Jetzt blicke ich dich mal durch.
Das Wasser bewegt die Magnet?
Also der pumpt hier quasi Wasser rein,
das bewegt...
Ich mein,
wenn man schon eh
eine Pumpe und Gedöns dafür braucht,
man könnte auch einfach eine Wasserkühlung nehmen.
Wo macht er denn die Hardware eigentlich hin?
Hier auf dieses Ding, oder?
Oder hier unten, oder?
Okay, ich muss etwas vorspulen.
Ah, hier kommt Hardware Zeug.
Oh!
Geht der Preis-Champ eigentlich noch?
Ja, ja, funktioniert noch.
easy
das ist kein rgb ram
das kann schonmal nix werden
weil wir letztens gelernt haben rgb ram ist ja auch schon nicht mehr
das beste bgra ram ist das
richtig der shit
bgr ram
also gibts doch ne wasserkühlung oder wie?
zyon magenta gelb ram das geht nicht
weil das ist ja additive farbmischung versus subtraktive farbmischung
und ram leuchtet ja selbst das heißt das funktioniert nicht
alles klar
aber warum?
ich dachte am anfang dass der einfach wild die luft hin und her schiebt und das das kühlt
aber wenn das doch eh einfach ne wasserkühlung wird warum nicht einfach ne wasserkühlung?
eine ernst gemeinte frage was macht eine wasserkühlung besser als eine normale aus meiner sicht nichts
also ich bevorzuge ganz normale luftkühlung schon ewig versus wasserkühlung
ich verstehe den sinn von diesem video nicht
okay ich muss jetzt mal ich muss oh nein ich muss jetzt mal vorspulen das ist richtig stumm
okay alter wie groß ist denn bitte schon dieses gehäuse what the fuck das ist ja ne tür
das sieht auch noch zusätzlich richtig hässlich aus das ding
was?
das da unten ist quasi sein wärmetauscher oder was also oder wie jetzt das da oben ist
wasserkühlung hier ist hier ist was ist denn das ist hier der radiator aber dann da müsste
ja hier luft pusten dass es hier kühlt oder so
also das hier schiebt quasi luft hier durch und es geht durch die kühlrippen und kühlt
dadurch das wasser runter
ja tatsächlich hier guck hier geht das hier kommt das hier kommt die luft wird die luft
rein gepustet und dann okay okay naja wieso steht oder weil das bei mir auf dem profil
steht und ich bisher noch keinen bock hatte in meinem profil was reinzuschreiben das passiert
wenn man zu viel zeit hat das passiert wenn man einen youtube channel hat mit solchem inhalt
dass man sich halt solche dinge aus den fingern saugen übrigens super s lige rgb beleuchtung
ist wahrscheinlich ja doch also ich weiß nicht
das aber auch mal hier ultra wide screen
ja mach mal
kann auch die geschwindigkeit regeln dass das mehr dass es schneller schneller pustet
ich meine die idee ist ist nicht nicht schlecht insgesamt so ich glaube nicht dass jetzt irgendein
hersteller hingeht und sagt so eine geile idee wir werden das jetzt einfach mal serienmäßig
was bauen weil das das ding da oben ist eine ganz normale wasserkühlung anscheinend so
und hier ist halt der wärmetauscher oder die rippen oder so man erkennt sich so richtig
also das spricht eigentlich kaum was dafür man könnte da auch einfach ganz normal lüfter
dran machen
mal was anderes das hier ist doch geschlossen sonst wird es ja mit dem druck überhaupt nicht
erhauen es muss ja geschlossen sein so wie kriegt er da neue luft rein weil das wärmt
sich doch auf also wenn er das mal angenommen da hat es jetzt irgendwie zwei tage am schluck
laufen das oder hatte hier irgendwelche ventile dass es quasi hier nach zieht so dass es
quasi hier raus pustet achter zieht das hier rein und puste das dann da raus also ja dann
ist ok dann funktioniert
der chat hat es wieder verstanden alles klar
hat gewisse ähnlichkeiten stimmt das stellzclown persönlich ja macht ja eigentlich ok also
ja warte mal das muss er noch hören
es hört sich an wie eine entfernte sirene aus half life
so jetzt überlegte mal jetzt überlegte mal jemand würde so einen fetten lüfter nehmen
also man muss ja auch den platz bedarf sich angucken jemand nimmt quasi einen was ist
das 60 cm lüfter und macht das einfach auf so eine wärmetauscher drauf das könntest
du auch nahezu unhörbar laufen lassen und würde es auch super kühlen
ich finde die idee cool also die die die idee ist cool es funktioniert aber es gibt sicherlich
noch 50 weitere felsbereich coole cooling systems die funktionieren die aber nicht wirklich
praktikabel sind ich meine ich meine ich könnte auch einfach im flugzeug rumfliegen und meinen
wärmetauscher unten aus dem aus dem flugzeug raushängen lassen das hat sicherlich auch
ganz guten airflow das aber auch nicht wirklich praktikabel
du kannst auch mit flüssigstückstoff genau wie das ist nicht praktikabel
ich dachte der bauer kühlt seine pc nur mit flüssigstückstoff wusste gar nicht dass
der überhaupt andere kühlmittel bei sich zu hause hat
so was gucken wir uns jetzt als nächstes an zeigt mal her
klar habe ich bilder an der wand hängen bilder sind äußerst praktikabel
was ist halt so eine bild unpraktikabel das ist ein viergisches holzding mit bild das
hängst du an die wand das macht genau das was es soll und ist ziemlich easy
was für bilder die von meinem opa
mein opa hat doch viele bilder gemalt da hängen hier einige rum
habe ich sogar mal ein video zugemacht fuck ich muss das video ich kann das jetzt hier
nicht suchen ich weiß gar nicht ob ich das im stream
zeigen darf weil auf dem in dem video sieht man sehr viel nackische nackische
medels die der opa gemalt hat ich glaube ich habe sogar das video unlisted
gemacht auf youtube weil es ja ich hatte ich glaube ich habe das video an ich muss
mal kurz gucken unlisted auf youtube gemacht weil youtube gesagt hat das ist ab 18 content
und es gibt irgendwie probleme oder sowas richtig hängen geblieben eigentlich
ja nur 18 plus nur 18 plus leute 18 18 plus video ist das ich glaube ist man
einziges 18 plus video auf dem auf dem channel ob ich was zeigen kann
ich kann ich kann es euch nicht zeigen das ist zu viel zu viel nackische bilder
drauf zu sehen ja
zwar quasi das hot tube stream seiner zeit aber der hat ja auch viele normale
bilder gemacht da hängen hier einige von rum
doch ich das video ist noch oben ich habe gerade geguckt so das wollte ich mir mal
gucken ich glaube ja dass ich schwachsinn ich glaube das ist komplett sinnlos aber
warum braucht man eine mit dem eine iot eine iot matratze das das möchte ich mir
jetzt mal erklären dass die
warum weil es geht und weil es wahrscheinlich eine app gibt die keine
ahnung schlafbewegung auf zeichnet oder keine ahnung also aber sagen wir mal so
eine matratze mit eingebauchter klimaanlage wäre schon cool gerade wenn
so warm ist
moment moment moment moment es ist eine matratze mit nee das ist man kann das
in raten bezahlen ich dachte das ist eine matratze mit einem monats abo das wäre
noch schöner ok ich kann entweder einmalig bezahlen 3000 dollar oder monatlich 82
dollar also nur ja ok man muss prioritäten setzen ja
ist eigentlich laut genug ja gibt es das gibt es das vielleicht auch in einer
ordentlichen einheit 91 grad was ist das
32 grad so und das andere was 65 18 grad ok das ist einfach mal nur halb so warm
kora juans her
ja das horrific
Hast du ein Firm, woher für?
Aber ich bin auch ein schrecklicher Schlaufer.
Ich werde mein Bestes tun, um in diesem Review positiv zu bleiben,
denn es sind mehr als 20 Jahre, seit ich die Qualität des Schlausens
auf diesem Schlaufer bekomme.
Und ich unterstütze die Art der Datakollektion, die 8Sleep macht.
Aber wir müssen über einige sehr bequemere Entscheidungen reden,
die 8Sleep in der Implementation ihrer Smart-Plattform gemacht hat.
Und obwohl sie signifizierend verbessert sind...
Florian, das stimmt. BTU ist immer noch die beste Einheit.
BTU pro Stunde. BTU pro Stunde.
Also, BTU ist wirklich best of bullshit Einheiten.
BTU ist die Menge an Wärmeenergie, die es braucht,
um ein britisches Pfund Wasser, um ein Grad Fahrenheit zu erwärmen.
Ein britisches Pfund, wohlgemerkt, ja.
Das ist die schlimmste Einheit aller Zeiten.
Was?
Ah.
Ich meine, wollen die ernsthaft, musste man ernsthaft ursprünglich
3000 Euro für ausgeben und einen Monatsbeitrag bezahlen?
Das ist doch nicht in den Ernst gewesen.
Das ist doch nicht mal ganz dicht.
Ja.
Mittlerweile hast du ja schon Monatsgebühren für alles mögliche.
Du brauchst acht Streaming-Services.
Du brauchst, was weiß ich, einen MMO.
Und jetzt noch neuerdings deine Matratze.
Und wo bloß Twitch Prime nicht zu vergessen.
Plus natürlich OnlyFans.
Da muss man natürlich zu den Monatsausgaben dabei rechnen.
Noch 20 OnlyFans Accounts.
Ich muss euch ehrlich sagen, ich habe nicht mal einen OnlyFans Account,
mit dem ich OnlyFans subscrib...
Also ich habe nicht eine OnlyFans Subscription.
Ich sehe das auch nicht ein.
Nicht Kappa.
Wirklich.
Warum glaubt ihr mir das nicht?
Ich habe keine OnlyFans Subscriptions.
Jaja.
Ah, super.
Super.
Das heißt nach zwei Jahren ist der Controller im Arsch.
Und ich brauche eine neue Matratze.
Obwohl meine Matratze eigentlich 10 Jahre gar...
What the...
Also ich bin der Ansicht, wenn man eine intelligente,
oder wie auch immer, Smart Matratze verkauft,
dann sollte man auch garantieren, dass die so lange funktioniert.
Ich meine, dass eine Matratze an sich länger als zwei Jahre hält,
sollte ja wohl selbstverständlich sein.
Aber was bringt es mir, wenn ich eine 3000 Euro super intelligente Matratze kaufe,
und die nach zwei Jahren kaputt ist,
und das einfach nur eine normale Matratze ist.
Was hast du eigentlich für einen komischen Fullscreen?
Was ist an meinem Fullscreen komisch?
Einheiten Tierliste.
Leute, die wichtigste Einheit ist Sekunde.
Wenn du Sekunde hast, kannst du fast alles andere draus machen.
Ja gut, Moment, Moment, Moment.
Ihr wollt mir jetzt nicht ernsthaft erzählen,
dass die Matratze das Gleiche macht wie irgendein Schlaflabor, oder?
Also das... ja.
Die Matratze kann ja wohl kaum mein...
Also was da so Schlaflabore machen,
ist zum Beispiel, die messen auch, wie viel Sauerstoff in deiner Atemluft
und sowas drin ist nachts, und ob du Luft anhältst und so.
Das kann die Matratze alles nicht messen.
Ist das ein Produktplacement, nein?
Ist es nicht?
Hätte ich auch gedacht, aber der ist da immer sehr gewissenhaft
mit Kennzeichen und es steht nirgendwo, ist es nicht?
Ich muss euch jetzt erklären, warum es nicht schlimm ist,
wenn man eine mit der Cloud verbundene,
dauer online seiende Matratze hat.
Moment, Moment, ist das...
Möchten die uns sagen, sie haben AI-gesteuerte Matratzentemperatur?
Oh man!
AI-gesteuerte...
Also man könnte auch hingehen, einfach einen Sensor einbauen
und versuchen, die Körpertemperatur auf so einem Niveau zu halten.
Aber das muss natürlich 1,5TB trained data sein,
dass man Smart Temp AI hat.
Es fehlt bloß noch Blockchain eingebaut.
Ist das nicht ein Widerspruch in sich?
Sleeping more in less time?
Mir ist klar, was die damit meinen.
Du legst acht Stunden im Bett und schläfst davon nur die Hälfte
oder du legst vier Stunden im Bett und schläfst alle vier,
ist schon klar, aber an sich dieser Satz ist...
Natürlich!
Moment, Moment, davon habe ich doch schon meine Apple Watch.
Meine Apple Watch sagt doch auch, wenn ich schwanger bin,
dass ich jetzt ins Krankenhaus muss, weil das Kind auf die Welt kommt.
Weil das merke ich ja vorher nicht.
Das geht nur, wenn ich eine Apple Watch habe.
Das stimmt, das ist nicht Farfetch, dass man das machen kann,
aber da brauchst du die Sensoren für.
Also eine Matratze bezweifle ich, dass die messen kann,
wie der Sauerstoffgehalt in meinem Blut oder in meiner Atemluft ist.
Und wenn sie das kann, würde ich mich eher fragen, warum kann sie das?
Und sobald der Anbieter dicht macht, funktioniert deine Matratze nicht mehr.
Aidsleep braucht diese Daten nicht nur für den Pod Pro,
um besser für dich zu arbeiten, aber auch um sich einen kompetenten
Vorteil in dem Markt zu geben, der bereits sehr saturiert ist.
Du wirst wahrscheinlich nicht überrascht sein, dass der Aidsleep Pod
keine Krankheiten diagnostizieren kann.
Und die Statistiken, die es dir gibt, sind mit Warnungen geblendet,
wie alle Menschen anders sind, und dass deine Statistiken
nicht in einer standarden Range generalisiert werden können.
Zumindest noch nicht.
Aber die Daten, die du direkt aus der Matratze hast,
und ein großer Teil der Aidsleep App,
fokussiert auf dir, deine Feedback zu geben.
Du musst es dir helfen.
Es wird dich Fragen über deine letzte Aidsleep-Session stellen,
wie war die Temperatur zu heiß während deiner Rem-Zycle?
Was ich ehrlich gesagt ziemlich unmöglich zu beantworten fand,
weil ich ein Aidsleeper war.
Aber ich werde das Beste tun, was ich kann.
Je mehr Daten sie bekommen, desto besser werden die Aidsleeper
nicht nur für mich, aber auch für alle anderen Aidsleeper.
Aber lass uns ehrlich sein.
Weißt du, wie das auf mich wirkt?
Die haben ein eigentlich ganz cooles Produkt gebaut.
Eine Matratze, die die Temperatur regeln kann.
Und flanschen da jetzt so viel drauf an,
dass es sich nach super high-tech Science-Fiction-Shit anhört,
was es eigentlich gar nicht ist.
Sie haben eine Matratze gebaut, die man Temperatur regulieren kann.
Das ist an sich schon eine coole Geschichte.
Wird aus meiner Sicht auch vollkommen ausreichen.
Aber jetzt versucht man da jetzt,
diesem Produkt noch 1000 Fähigkeiten anzudichten.
Ich möchte 3.000 Dollar für etwas bezahlen, das in der Zukunft funktionieren könnte.
Die große Frage ist, ob es jetzt funktioniert.
Und für mich ist die Antwort ja.
Bevor ich zu viele Details über meine Probleme eingehen,
bin ich kein guter Schlaufer.
Und ich habe es seit mehr als 20 Jahren nicht gemacht.
Für irgendeine Grundlage habe ich eine schlechte Abwechslung in meinen Füßen.
Time to fall asleep, drei Minuten?
What the fuck?
Ist der Scheintot, wenn er ins Bett fällt, oder was?
In drei Minuten habe ich mich doch nicht mal so hingelegt, dass ich schlafen könnte.
Aber meine Temperaturkurve, die die 8Sleep nennt,
die Autopilot, ist immer an positiven Temperaturen gesetzt.
Als ich mein Initial-Setup gemacht habe,
hat die App mir gesagt, dass Menschen wie ich
am besten am Plus-Zero-Temperatur fallen,
und dann minus eins während der Nacht schlafen.
Und im Interesse der Wissenschaft,
habe ich mich dafür entschieden, einen Schuss zu geben.
Und ich habe fast die ganze Nacht geschlafen.
Ich fühlte mich, als ob ich tot war.
Aber jetzt, dass ich es in meinen persönlichen Kurven gedildet habe,
habe ich in 20 Jahren nicht so gut geschlafen.
Wie gesagt, habe ich auch viele Fragen in der App geantwortet,
wie ich es in meinen Kurven gedildet habe.
Es wäre auch möglich, dass es einfach daran liegt,
dass wenn es zu warm ist,
dass man nicht ordentlich schlafen kann.
Keine Ahnung, wie es bei ihm ist.
Vielleicht wird es die nächste Zeit,
dass eine Person wie ich das 8Sleep-App laden wird.
Es wird sie am ersten Abend nicht zerstören.
Okay, genug von mir.
Schauen wir uns ein bisschen näher an.
Es hat eine Basisstation,
die mit Wasser und Hydrogen peroxide gefüllt ist.
Das sieht aus wie so eine Staubsauger-
Roboter-Entleerungsstation.
Es hat auch ein Abillikalkorb,
das den Topper an den Hauptenten verbindet.
Der Hauptenten hat natürlich einen Pump
und ein paar Equipment, um das Wasser zu heizen und zu coolen.
Aber es ist fast silenzig,
und ich habe es nie über den Sound von unserem Fan gehört.
Das ist der Sound
des 8Sleeps,
set to maximum cool Temperatur.
Also, ich würde das hören.
Wie ich vorhin erwähnt habe, kann die Maschine
an einigen Temperaturunits von minus 10 zu plus 10 sein.
Und ich habe in anderen Reviews erwähnt,
dass die Maschine
so niedrig wie 55°F oder
so hoch wie 110°C kann können.
Ich konnte commentieren,
dass die Maschine
so niedrig wie 55°F oder
so hoch wie 110°C kann können.
Aber ich kann damit ergebensformen,
dass die Temperatur zucount Pigcoin halter als
herbNT denn die Temperatur et гnusRd^^
Also ich bin mir nicht sicher, dass die eigentlichen Nummern so wichtig sind.
Wie ich schon erwähnt habe, kann die Schleimhaut die Temperatur der Schleimhaut verändern,
um die Schleimhaut zu modifizieren.
Aber es hat auch eine Schleimhaut, um die Schleimhaut für jeden Tag bereit zu haben.
Es gibt vier Temperatur-Stages, die in der 8-Sleep-Autopilot-Kurve definiert werden.
Der erste ist die initiale Temperatur oder was die Schleimhaut zu fühlen ist.
Der zweite ist die tiefen Schleimhaut, die generell die erste Schleimhaut,
die man am Anfang der Nacht im Schleimhaut befindet.
Und danach ist die Rehm-Temperatur.
Mit dem Autopilot wird die 8-Sleep-Autopilot die Schleimhaut verwendet,
um die besten Nachtschleimhaut zu verwenden.
Wenn Sie das nicht wollen, können Sie...
Irgendwie sieht das übertrieben kompliziert aus für eine Matratze.
...manual modifizieren und Ihre eigenen Temperaturen zu definieren.
Die letzte Temperatur, die Sie aufsetzen können, ist Ihre Schleimhauttemperatur.
Für mich wird ein dünneres Heating im Bett am Morgen mich natürlich aufwachen.
Das ist ein seltsames Subkonsens.
Und jetzt habe ich die 8-Sleep-Autopilot für ungefähr zwei Monate.
Ich habe ziemlich vergessen, dass es sogar ein Setup ist.
Und ich wache natürlich um die selbe Zeit, jeden Tag,
ohne einen traditionellen Alarm,
nur von einigen Grad Temperaturveränderung in der Matratze.
Es gibt auch die Möglichkeit,
Ihren Seiten der Matratze zu vibrieren,
entweder leicht oder violent.
Aber ich fand, dass sogar die leichteste Vibration
ziemlich faszinierend wäre.
Und es war nicht nötig für mich.
Wenn Sie nicht haben, um am Morgen aufzuwachen,
kann ich Ihnen ziemlich garantieren,
dass Sie nicht durch diesen Setup schlafen werden.
Mein einziger Schleimhauttemperatur ist,
dass es mir zu früh aufwacht.
Beide meine Frau und ich haben uns beschlossen,
was kostet die 3.000 Dollar?
Ja, die Daten auszulesen wäre schon ganz cool.
Aber die wollen das ja nicht hergeben.
Die wollen den Kram ja nur einsammeln
und wollen nicht, dass du damit was machst.
Also ohne Irre.
Es gibt überhaupt keinen Grund,
warum dieses Ding unbedingt Cloud-Verbindung braucht.
Außer Ihre zusammenfantasierte Geschichte
von Krankheitserkennung und AI und was auch immer.
]?
?
Ich verstehe es auch nicht.
Dann bauen Sie ein Produkt, was an sich ja ganz cool ist.
Eine temperaturgeregene Matratze.
Lassen sie mit diesen ganzen AI-Schwachsinnen und so was weg.
Das ist ja ein cooles Ding, aber dann kannst du es praktisch in nichts Gescheites integrieren.
Das ist doch alles, das ist doch sowas halbherzig jetzt wieder.
Also eine Sache, die bei mir hilft, ist, wenn es warm ist, also jetzt gerade im Sommer, ich mache einfach eine Viertelstunde, bevor ich ins Bett gehe, die Klimaanlage an und lasse die wirklich richtig ordentlich kühlen, dann dauert so eine halbe Stunde, 45 Minuten, dann ist es zwar wieder zu warm, aber in der Zeit ist man meistens schon eingepennt.
Alles ist weg, ja, das ist das hauptsächliche Problem.
Evolutioner Sleep Science jetzt. Es ist eine temperaturgeregelte Matratze, das ist ein cooles Produkt, aber das, was die da drumherum stricken, finde ich, ist einfach wieder zu aufgesetzt.
Dann könnte man sich überlegen, hat mich jetzt nicht so überzeugt.
Wie gesagt, ich finde das Produkt an sich nice, ja, aber das, was die sich da drumherum zusammendichten, nee, wirklich nicht.
Muss echt nicht sein. So, was gucken wir uns jetzt an? Was Activate, warum habe ich denn das ausgewählt? Wahrscheinlich langweilig.
Epische Mittelalter Schlacht, ne, habe ich nicht mehr gespielt. Das wollte ich mir holen, ich fand den ersten Teil wirklich extrem cool.
Das gucken wir jetzt auch nicht. Gunsave, Kokona Time, jawoll.
Wir brauchen sowas ja nicht, aber in Amis ist natürlich so ein Gunsave, das ist wichtig.
Okay, das Video geht 1.53, da wackelt zweimal dran, das ist offen.
Und das Lock ist wahrscheinlich so schlecht, dass er zweimal wackelt, das ist offen.
Ja, chat, finde ich auch, sieht billig aus, das Ding. So irgendwie einmal zu fest drauf gehauen, das ist auf hier vorne, aber wahrscheinlich ist es das gar nicht.
Ich glaube, das Einfachste ist wahrscheinlich wirklich das, was er jetzt macht. Einfach, wenn du krasse Lockpicking Skills hast wie er, dreimal wackelt und es ist offen.
Ah, das ist doch schlecht.
Okay, das ist echt schlecht.
Das ist schneller, als wenn du den Original Schlüssel nimmst.
Das musst du auch erstmal hinkriegen, dass du schneller öffnest als mit dem Original Schlüssel.
Das ist das amerikanischste Video, das ich je gesehen habe. Was ist das denn?
Irgendeine Pistolenmagnethaltung fürs Auto. Ja gut, Freedom, das braucht man. Natürlich, unglaublich wichtig.
Also wenn man nicht seine G18 gleich mal griffbereit hat im Auto, dann geht da ganz schnell was in die Hose.
Das ist auch eine G18, oder? Na das jetzt nicht, aber das davor ist eine G18, oder? Das, das, das da, das ist auch eine G18, oder?
So meine Battlefield-Kenntnisse sagen mir, das ist eine G18.
Das ist jetzt was anderes. Aber warum?
Ist das bei den Amis wirklich so, dass die permanent in Straßenschießereien geraten, dass du on the fly am Fahrer sitzt, deine Pistole griffbereit haben musst?
Die Like-Anzahl.
Alter.
Was? Norddeutscher Unternehmer regt sich auf. Ist das ein Legit-Video, oder ist das ein Fake-Video? Also ist das wirklich ein Norddeutscher Unternehmer, oder jemand der tut, als wäre das ein Norddeutscher Unternehmer?
Das ist mega. Okay, okay. Mal gucken. Wenn der Chat das sagt.
Ich würde gerne halt hier das Dach in Ordnung bringen, einen vernünftigen Estrich machen und dann könnten wir hier halt produzieren.
Das Ding ist, ich brauche hier. Das Dach sieht fast so gut aus wie mal ursprünglich in meiner Garage. Und dann könnten wir hier halt produzieren.
Das Ding ist, ich brauche hier, weil wir sind im Außenbereich, da brauche ich eine, möchte eine, muss eine Umnutzung machen, weil das ist ja hier landwirtschaftlich genutzt. Sieht man ja. Sieht man ja. Okay.
Da brauche ich also eine Umnutzung und die Umnutzung findet auf dem Formular vom Bauantrag statt. Das heißt also, es ist ein Bauantrag. Und ein Bauantrag im Außenbereich, der wird jetzt mal abgelehnt.
Jetzt soll das Amt Neukloster den Flächennutzungsplan ändern. Ja, Bürokratie ist schon was Tolles.
Soll die Gemeinde einen Bebauungsplan machen und dann kann ich einen Bauantrag stellen. Verstehst du? Aber die ganzen Planer, die sich natürlich darüber freuen über die Regelung, die bezahle ich. Kann ich aber nicht.
Ich meine, ich habe ja auch keinen Ducaten Esel, der Geld scheißt oder was. Bestellen die sich dann sowas vor? Das ist ganz einfach. Politischer Wille ist nicht da, dass ich hier produzieren kann.
Weißt du, was sie zu mir sagen? Sie sagen zu mir, wir wollen die die Zersiedelung des ländlichen Raumes aufhalten.
Hier oben, Alter. Guck mal raus.
Aber alles kein Problem. Deutschland wird der Leitmarkt für Computerspiele in Zukunft. Das ist genauso realistisch.
Wenn du hier rausguckst, da kannst du bis zum Horizont geht ein Feld und wenn du an dem Horizont stehst, da kannst du nochmal bis zum Horizont.
Ist aber noch der gleiche Feld. Ja, hat er recht.
Meine Frau kommt aus Münsterland. Da ist Zersiedlung. Ja, da kann man das so sehen.
Aber das ist schön. Das ist eine schöne Landschaft. Und hier ist Agrarwüste.
Und wenn einer kommt und möchte und möchte halt irgendwelche alten Stelle irgendwie nutzen.
Dann haben sie mir jetzt einen Verwaltungslotsen. Ja gut, das brauchst du ja auch, sonst blickst du.
Das geht ja nimmer. Der unteren Verwaltungsbehörde.
Hört euch doch mal selber. Hört man sich also selber zu?
Wenn ich mit Abitur nicht mehr in der Lage bin, mich durch die Stromschnellen meiner Verwaltung, die ich bezahle, die für mich da ist.
Ja, das ist das Problem. Die sollte eigentlich, Behörden und Richtlinien sollten eigentlich dafür da sein,
nicht die Sache unnötig komplizierter zu machen, sondern dass es eine klare Linie, eine klare Struktur gibt,
dass es die Sache eigentlich von der Idee her einfacher und durchschaubarer macht, nachvollziehbarer macht.
Das ist aber mittlerweile so ausgeartet in vielen Bereichen, dass du es komplett vergessen kannst.
Da können wir es lassen. Also Leute, ich hab Bock, was anzupacken, ich hab Bock, die Welt zu verbessern, aber irgendwann muss ich auch mitmachen.
Ansonsten können wir es lassen. Und jetzt sitzen wir da in einer Produktionshalle, nicht genehmigt, illegal.
Und wir haben einen Haufen solcher, die wollen unbedingt, dass die Leute vom Land in die Stadt ziehen.
Da haben sie mir angeboten bei Wismar, da saß der Bürgermeister neben mir, da hatten wir einen Termin bei der Landräte.
Da haben sie gesagt, dann gehen sie doch nach Wismar. Auf der grünen Wiese, da ist eine grüne Wiese.
Es gibt ja gar kein Problem in dem Sinne. Also eigentlich ist die Sache vom Ansatz her ziemlich easy.
Ja, verstehe ich.
Guck mal hier, das musst du dir mal angucken. Da hat sich mal einer hingestellt und hat den Stein, der ist ja so nicht gewachsen,
hat sich hingestellt mit Hammer und Meißen und hat den Stein hier eckig geschlagen.
Vor 200 Jahren. Und da baue ich mir eine Halle auf der grünen Wiese aus Blech.
Das stimmt schon, da hat er recht. Die Leute, die sowas entscheiden, ich weiß jetzt nicht, was er sagt,
aber die Leute, die sowas entscheiden, sind erstens Leute, die davon keine Ahnung haben.
Das ist aber gar nicht so sehr das Problem. Das eigentliche Problem ist, das sind Leute, denen es scheißegal ist,
die keinerlei persönliches Interesse daran haben, noch irgendwie bei schlechten Entscheidungen fürchten müssen,
dass es persönliche Auswirkungen für sie hat.
Leute, die haben Verwaltung, haben die gelernt. Verwaltung, das sind von Beruf Verwalter. Die verwalten unseren Reichtum.
Es geht für ein Paar, aber wir können nicht alle mit einem MacBook und einem Chai Latte in Berlin in einem Co-Working-Space sitzen
und die zehnte Dating-App erfinden. Es gibt auch ein paar Leute, die irgendwas anfassen müssen und sich die Hände schmutzig machen.
Ansonsten geht es halt nicht. Es funktioniert anders nicht. Und wir machen halt Realwirtschaft.
Das heißt, wir haben mit Produkten, mit Sachen, mit Materie zu tun. Und dafür brauchen wir nur mal Platz.
Das ist doch nicht, das kann man doch verstehen oder nicht?
Ja.
Da scheiße ich auf die scheiß Glasfaser drauf. Ich brauche Platz.
Auf Glasfaser scheiße ich nicht. Das muss zusätzlich auch noch hin.
Ja, verstehe ich. Also kann ich komplett nachvollziehen.
Wir brauchen 5G. Für die Entwicklung des ländlichen Raumes brauchen wir 5G.
Boah, ich kriege eins zu viel.
Ja gut, das eine, man braucht das alles oder der Typ ist immer noch nicht fertig.
Er hat ja nicht unrecht.
Aber 5G und Glasfaser ist ja eine Sache, die kannst du trotzdem noch machen.
Soll ich euch mal was erzählen, dass das alles echt nicht so einfach ist?
Stellt euch vor, ihr habt einen Baum in eurem Garten stehen und ihr wollt den Baum wegmachen.
Meint ihr, ihr dürft einfach in euren eigenen Garten gehen und euren eigenen Baum umhacken?
Nein. Natürlich nicht. Das geht nicht.
So, das heißt, du musst erstmal einen Antrag stellen.
Ich frage mich nicht mal, wie der Kram heißt.
Du musst einen Antrag stellen, dass du deinen... genau, das kommt nämlich auch noch dabei.
Du musst einen Antrag stellen, dass du den Baum fällen darfst.
Dann muss erstmal geguckt werden, dass es die richtige Zeit ist,
weil du darfst Bäume erst ab einem gewissen Datum nicht mehr fällen.
So, dann kommt irgendein Typ vorbei und guckt sich den Baum an.
Dann entscheidet vielleicht mal irgendjemand, ob du deinen eigenen Baum auf deinem eigenen Grundstück fällen darfst.
So, und dann kommen sie noch auf die Idee und sagen, ja, es gibt aber noch ein paar Auflagen.
Zum Beispiel, wenn du jetzt einen Baum fällst, dann bist du verpflichtet dazu, einen neuen Baum zu pflanzen.
Also sprich, wenn ich jetzt einen großen Baum fälle bei mir im... wahrscheinlich, ja.
Wenn ich jetzt einen großen Baum bei mir fälle im Garten, dann muss ich einen kleinen Baum neu pflanzen.
Habe ich gemacht. Habe ich gemacht. Jetzt kommt der Hit.
Und jetzt kommt der Hit. Es gibt ja übrigens auch genauer Auflagen, was das sein muss und was es nicht sein darf und so.
Und jetzt ist es so, du kannst nicht einfach den Baum fällen, einen neuen Baum pflanzen und dann sagen,
okay, ist gut, habe ich gemacht, alles klar. Der Typ kommt vorbei, guckt, ob du wirklich den Baum gepflanzt hast,
ob das der richtige Baum ist, ob das richtig gemacht ist, ob das alles okay ist.
Und jetzt kommt der Hit. Jetzt kommt der Hit.
Es gab wahrscheinlich genug Leute, die den neuen Baum danach einfach wieder rausgesandt haben.
Der kommt sogar random nach 1-2 Jahren nochmal vorbei und guckt, ob der Baum noch steht, der neue, den du gepflanzt hast.
Also was ist das denn? Es ist mein Garten, es ist mein Baum. Die können mich mal am Arsch lecken.
Ich meine, ich habe es jetzt gemacht, du hast ja keine andere Chance.
Übrigens, es wird ja noch besser. Es wird ja noch besser.
Wir haben letztens noch einen Baum gefällt und da haben wir auch wieder einen Antrag gestellt.
Das darf man ja bis Ende Februar oder so machen.
Und dann haben wir den Baum fällen lassen und dann lag dann halt der Baum gefällt und zerstückelt im Garten rum.
Wenn ihr mal einen großen Baum im Garten liegen hattet, das ist ganz schön viel und das ist schwer und das ist ein großer Haufen.
Also das räumst du nicht einfach mal nebenbei weg.
Das lag da jetzt, keine Ahnung, 3-4 Wochen rum und da habe ich im Internet geguckt,
was gibt es denn so für Unternehmen, die den Kram abtransportieren.
Ich hätte auch die andere Option gehabt, ich hätte es bei eBay Kleinanzeigen reinstellen können und sagen hier, kostenlos Holz, nehme mit.
Also, ich habe einen gesucht, habe angerufen und habe gesagt, hier, wir brauchen Baum, Baum entsorgen.
So, dann kam der Typ und hat den Baum entsorgt.
Der Kerl selbst war echt super, der hat von morgens bis abends geschafft, bis der Baum weg war.
Aber auf einmal steht einer vom Amt vor der Tür.
So random, klingelt es und es steht einer vom Amt vor der Tür.
Ja, was ist? Und dann meinte er, er hätte einen Anruf erhalten, wir würden hier illegal einen Baum fällen.
Also sprich, irgendjemand hat uns auch noch verpetzt, was ja gar nicht stimmt.
Wir haben ja gar nicht illegal einen Baum gefällt, wir haben den Baum mit Antrag vollkommen korrekt im Februar gefällt.
Der lag dann aber halt ein paar Wochen rum und lag da halt so vor sich hin.
Und irgendjemand hat an dem Tag aus dem Fenster geguckt und hat festgestellt, die haben einen Baum im Garten liegen, da rufe ich doch jetzt mal beim Amt an.
Und dann kam ein Typ vom Amt vorbei und musste sich das nochmal angucken.
Alter, meine Fresse, was denn ein Scheiß, das ist der Wahnsinn, das ist mein Garten, das ist mein Baum.
Warum muss ich überhaupt mit irgendjemand auf der Welt reden, dass ich meinen Baum in meinem Garten fällen darf?
Das ist so lächerlich alles.
Es ist nichts passiert, der Typ vom Amt ist vorbei gekommen, hat gesagt, er hat einen Anruf gekriegt, wir hätten illegal einen Baum gefällt.
Da haben wir gesagt, wir haben den Baum nicht illegal gefällt, hier ist der Antrag, alles zugestimmt, war schon im Februar.
Da hat er gesagt, okay, dann haut er wieder ab. Fertig, das war's.
Aber irgendeinem Nachbarschafts-Opa hat es nicht gefallen, dass wir da Baum abtransportiert haben.
warrior
Nee, also, so bürokratische Sachen ist hier ist echt absolut lächerlich.
Deswegen muss ich ja auch immerketten, wenn sie irgendwie erzählen, ja wir werden führend im Bereich der digitalen Ämter.
Deswegen haben unsere Gesundheitsämter immer noch Faxe zu Corona verschickt und so was oder wir werden ein Leitmarkt für Computerspiele oder wir werden das schnellste Internet bekommen bleiben.
Wir labern immer nur, wir schwätzen immer den ganzen Tag ohne irgendeinen nachhaltigen Plan dafür zu haben, wie man das auch umsetzen kann.
Es wird einfach die letzten, also vor allem die letzten 20 Jahre übertrieben, mein Eindruck zumindest, wird einfach zu 95% geschwätzt und irgendein Datum genannt, was so weit in der Zukunft liegt, dass man das überhaupt nicht mehr mit den Aussagen, die man damals getroffen hat, in Verbindung bringt.
Naja, es ist voll viel Arsch. Naja, gut.
So, was gucken wir uns jetzt als nächstes an? Jetzt halt mal her.
Das haben wir uns angeguckt. Oh, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, please, please, please, please. Kein, kein, kein, nichts jetzt. Kein, das ist mir zu dramatisch, das halte ich jetzt nicht aus.
Okay, also was gucken wir uns an? Warum, was will er uns eigentlich mit seinem Windows aktivieren hier sagen? Ich skippe da mal kurz durch.
So, Windows XP was released almost 20 years ago and back then they manufactured specific XP versions for certain OEMs, for instance Dell or IBM.
What's so special about those versions? Windows XP hat man doch, dachte ich, immer über so ein Registry-File aktiviert.
Naja, das übertreibt man nicht. Alter, was ist das für Musik hier im Hintergrund? Das ist bestimmt TOS.
Das ist bestimmt TOS. Ja, über die Hotline. Ja, das kenne ich noch.
Da musstest du anrufen, das kenne ich noch, da musstest du anrufen und dann hattest du so einen, wie nennt man das, so einen Menü-Roboter dran und musstest Dinge durchklicken.
Das geht immer noch. Das geht bestimmt immer noch.
Ich habe das mal probiert, ich habe mir mal bei irgendeinem Key-Shop einen eindeutig, nennt man es mal einen relativ sicher ungültigen Key gekauft für glaube ich 30 Cent.
Ich wollte einfach mal gucken, ob das funktioniert. Das war ein Windows 10 Key, da dachte ich mir schon, das kann im Leben nicht funktionieren.
Und du kannst ja bei Windows XP auch so ein Hilfefenster aufmachen, wenn der Key nicht funktioniert.
Da habe ich dem Typ vom Support, da geht dann so eine Chatbox auf, dem Typ vom Support halt geschrieben, ich habe den Key auf Amazon legit erworben und der hat sich aber nicht überreden lassen.
Die haben gesagt, nein, nein, das ist ein ungültiger Key, ich soll mich an meinen Händler wenden, blablabla, aber er hat ja anscheinend einen gültigen Key.
Das ist richtige Pippe-Please-Musik. Das geht bestimmt immer noch.
Auf, mach, mach, mach.
Alter, das geht aber lang, okay, wir skippen ein bisschen durch gleich.
Das ist Peter vom Microsoft Support.
Was?
Ja, auf, mach hinne.
Also da geht mittlerweile schon deutlich bessere synthetische Sprache als das.
Das hat sich eher nach Baguette angehört.
Alter, geht das, das geht wahrscheinlich 20 Minuten jetzt so weiter.
Was? Warum?
Das ist so ein Captcha übers Telefon.
Das ist bestimmt irgendeine Cortana-Eye dahinter.
Was ist das Problem?
Wo ist das Problem?
Oh, oh, zu schnell.
Alter, diese schlechte Speech, Text-to-Speech-Trigger hat mich richtig.
Ach, das war jetzt okay.
Ach, das war jetzt okay, vorher nicht, alles klar.
Was?
Oh Gott, ist das schlecht.
Yes.
Das ist ja heftig.
Okay, schafft das jetzt so irgendwo?
Ah, hier geht es weiter.
Alter, okay, wie lange geht das jetzt noch?
Schafft das denn am Ende eigentlich noch?
Scheint zu funktionieren.
Warum fangen die mit C zu G an und machen dann A und B?
Das Ding kackt voll ab, das kackt voll ab.
Okay, und funktioniert es? Hey, es ist aktiviert.
Meine Güte, was nackt er?
Es hat ja schon weh getan, nur beim Zugucken.
So, was gucken wir uns jetzt an?
Epische Mittelalter-Schlachten, Battlefield 3 Top-Plays hätten wir auch noch zu bieten.
Github Copilot.
Ich glaube, diese Github Copilot-Geschichte hat Microsoft nur rausgebracht, dass ganz viele Leute Github-Memes produzieren.
Ich habe letzte Woche kaum was mehr Postings gesehen als zu Github Copilot.
Auf Twitter, jeder hat sich drüber lustig gemacht.
Zum Beispiel, wenn du eine Funktion nennst, do I suck, kommt zurück, automatisch AI-Completed-Return, yes.
Und sowas, also.
Okay, AI-Blockchain, jawoll.
Beleise.
Microsoft.
Wer das nicht kennt, ich werde mal ganz kurz sagen, was das ist.
Das ist eine künstliche Intelligenz trainiert mit dem Source-Code, der auf Github ist, der Code-Vorschläge für dich macht.
Also man schreibt, was man haben möchte, und die AI versucht dann, das zu programmieren, was man ihr gesagt hat.
Klappt mehr oder weniger gut.
Aber ich glaube, vom Ansatz her ist das wirklich die Zukunft. Jetzt nicht wirklich für Smartphone-App-Entwicklung oder sowas in der Richtung.
Aber ich glaube, dass wenn wir das schaffen, oder ich muss das anders erzählen.
Also, es gibt ja schon jede Menge trainierte EIs, die relativ gut sind.
Die allerdings oftmals, wenn sie daneben liegen, total daneben liegen.
Zum Beispiel, es gab mal, ich glaube von Google oder Microsoft, ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, gab es mal so eine Bildbeschreibungs-EI, oder was es gab, gibt es so eine Bildbeschreibungs-EI.
Da lädst du zum Beispiel was hoch.
Keine Ahnung, du hast deine Oma auf der Terrasse fotografiert im Schaukelstuhl.
Und du lädst das da hoch, und dann sagt dir die AI auf dem Bild, ist zu sehen, äh, äh, elderly woman on, äh, was weiß ich, äh, on a chair, kommt dann zurück.
Also, die Dinger sind dann relativ gut im Erkennen, aber wenn die verkehrt liegen, dann liegen sie meistens meilenweit verkehrt.
Also sprich, du, wenn du deine Katze auf dem Sofa fotografierst, und die AI sich vertut, dann kommt da nicht etwa raus, äh, Katze auf dem Stuhl anstatt Katze auf dem Sofa.
Da kommt dann raus, Vulkanausbruch in Island, oder sowas.
Also, wenn das falsch liegt, dann liegt das oftmals meilenweit falsch.
Ja, oder, oder, keine Ahnung, du hast, du fotografierst irgendwie, äh, du springst in, in, in, in den Swimmingpool in deinem Garten, und lädst das da hoch, und die AI macht's falsch, erkennt's falsch, und da kommt dann, keine Ahnung, Potwale bei der Paarung erkannt, oder sowas.
Also, wenn das falsch liegt, liegt das oftmals krass, also total daneben, ja.
Und, gerade in diesem Bereich, so das, das, der, der möglichen Selbstoptimierung, da seh ich schon viel Zukunft drin.
Fühl mich beleidigt, ja, ihr habt recht, ihr habt recht, war vielleicht, war vielleicht gar nicht so weit weg von der Realität, ja, ist ja gut.
Aber, gerade, gerade in diesem Bereich, seh ich da schon, seh ich da schon einiges, einiges in, an Potenzial, ja.
Ok, gucken wir uns mal an.
Jithub.
Ja, das ist auch mega geil.
Das hat Microsoft gekauft.
Genau.
Richtig.
Genau, guck, du schreibst einen Kommentar, das, das soll die AI programmieren, und dann macht die AI das.
Nur, dass das halt noch ein bisschen, naja.
AI gegen Captures gibt's schon.
Wer hat da eigentlich den Copyright für den Code, das ist ne echt gute Idee.
Wer hat da eigentlich den Copyright für den Code, das ist ne echt gute Frage.
Das ist, das ist das nächste Level von Stack Overflow-Triphan-Programming.
Du gehst jetzt nicht einfach nur auf Stack Overflow und copy-pastest, du hast direkt die AI im Editor, die irgendwas für dich zusammenwurstet.
Das wird ne ganz neue Ebene von Sicherheitslücken geben, nämlich AI-generierte Sicherheitslücken.
Da, im Internet auch irgendwie, aus Internetverbindung.
Leute, Java oder Java, was sagt ihr?
Ich, ich persönlich mag Java, JavaScript, ich sag auch JavaScript und nicht JavaScript.
Java, ah, ich weiß nicht.
Wie oft kopierst du noch aus Stack Overflow?
Stack Overflow stündlich.
Da muss ich ja, dann muss ich jetzt erst noch durchlesen, was die AI programmiert hat, bis ich verstanden hab, was die AI programmiert hat, dann hätt ich's wahrscheinlich auch selbst programmiert.
Haben die jetzt in Wishlist, haben wir nicht letztens das aktuelle Wishlist Studio Preview ausprobiert?
Die haben da auch so komisches Zeug drin versucht mit Autocomplete AI und das hat überhaupt nicht funktioniert.
Aber, es gibt doch gar kein Element-ID zur Zeit, was Button heißt. Na gut, das kann er, das kann er ja eigentlich wissen.
Ich mein, das ist echt schon ziemlich big brain und wenn man sich überlegt, man kann sich da jetzt lustig machen, so viel man drüber will, wenn man sich überlegt, dass es ja noch ganz am Anfang ist und wie, ich sag mal in Anführungsstrichen, gut oder clever das jetzt schon funktioniert, auch wenn du jetzt noch damit nicht einfach fertig hinschreiben lassen kannst, es geht und es funktioniert, das ist ja immer noch, wir sind ja da immer noch ziemlich am Anfang.
Überlegt euch mal, wie das in 10 Jahren ausschaut. Und spätestens wenn das Zeug wirklich anfangen kann, an sich selber rum zu feilen und zu verbessern, dann geht's ab.
Schafft man sich damit nicht selbst irgendwann als Projekter?
Schafft man sich damit nicht selbst irgendwann als Programmierer ab?
Ne, das glaube ich nicht. Das glaube ich nicht. Ich glaube, es geht da eher um so Optimierung, wie zum Beispiel, dass der Bilderkennungsalgorithmus eben immer besser Bilder erkennt und sich da quasi selbst verbessert.
Es ist nicht um das eigentliche Programm und den kreativen Prozess dahinter. Einfach, dass die Dinge viel effizienter sind, Dinge durchzuprobieren und die notwendigen Informationen daraus zu holen.
Ich kann es auch schlecht einschätzen, aber ich glaube nicht, dass wir mit Terminator Sachen da rechnen müssen. Aber im Bereich, sagen wir mal sowas wie Text-to-Speech oder Bildererkennung oder es gibt ja mittlerweile schon Services, die fassen dir Texte zusammen und sowas. Ich glaube, in dem Bereich könnte das richtig, richtig gute Verbesserung bringen.
Ich glaube nicht, dass es so weit kommen wird, dass man eine AI hat zur Bildererkennung, die auf einmal dann selber, wo er sich umprogrammiert, zu einer AI zur Steuerung des Flugverkehrs oder sowas. Das ist dann vielleicht ein bisschen sehr Science-Fiction-Style mäßig weiter geholt.
Aber wir werden es erleben. Und ein Vorteil hat es, AIs müssen keine Daily-Scrums machen.
Ich glaube, Co-Pilot hat einen guten Job gemacht. Es fühlt sich ein wenig an, um die Bedingungen zu machen, aber es ist die beste AI-Coding-Erleichterung, die ich je gehabt habe. Aber wie funktioniert das eigentlich?
Wie funktioniert das eigentlich? In Ordnung, um eine nutzvolle AI zu bauen, braucht man viel Daten. Leider haben die Entwickler über die letzten zwölf Jahre grüßlich ihre Zeit und Kode gedeiht, um anderen Entwicklern auf der Internet zu helfen, während sie ihre Copyright zu diesem Content vergleichen. V.a. auf der Website Stack Overflow, die dieses Monat nur für 1,8 Billion Dollar gekauft wurde.
Oh, ja, das habe ich mitgekriegt. Nee, nee, nee. Äh, wer hat Stack Overflow gekauft? Das war nicht Microsoft. Das war irgendwas, wo ich vorher noch nichts von gehört hatte.
Das ist richtig Big Brain. Das hat Microsoft gekauft. Ept3 hat Microsoft alles gekauft. Ja, ja, ja, genau, genau, das meine ich, das riecht gut.
Das riecht gut. Die heißen nicht wirklich SUS, die das gekauft haben, oder? Ah nee, Pro-SUS.
Die üblichen Verdächtigen mal wieder. Aber Microsoft hat das gekauft.
Oder so. Okay, sie haben es nicht gekauft, sie haben die Exklusivrechte, es zu benutzen. Kommt ja, kommt ja für uns ausgleichen aus.
Die Developers, jawoll. Warum ZDF? Lief das wirklich im ZDF?
Das ist ja aktuell so ein Trend, dass man Sachen Open nennt, die nicht Open sind. Ach, das ist Tencent. Na, das darf ja nicht fehlen.
Developers, Developers, Developers. Ja.
Up, yes, Big Brain.
Das ist der Traum der BWL Leute. Man braucht nur noch BWL Leute, keine Programmierer mehr. Aber wenn wir an diesem Punkt sind, dann haben sie eins vergessen, lange bevor du keine Programmierer brauchst, brauchst du schon keine BWL Leute mehr.
Also wenn es mal so weit gekommen ist, dass du quasi Programmierer und Loginsachen, also kreative Sachen durch AI ersetzen kannst, dann kannst du BWL und sonstige Dinge schon viel, viel früher ersetzen.
Amazon ist auch am Start, ja, was sonst?
Jetzt mal ernsthaft, so lächerlich diese Pressekonferenzen damals gewesen sind, das war mir lieber als dieses emotionale Rumgequatschen bei Windows 11.
Also das fand ich ja wirklich grausam. Der Typ hat ja fast geweint bei Windows 11 auf der Bühne, als er das angekündigt hat, weil das so emotional ist.
Was? Ist das nicht so?
Also bei der Windows 11 Pressekonferenz, die haben ja wirklich fast geweint beim Windows vorstellen.
So, wir gucken jetzt Battlefield 3. Ich muss jetzt noch eine Runde Battlefield 3 gucken, bevor ich Mittagessen gehe, ich habe mega Hunger. Aber eine Runde Battlefield 3 muss noch sein.
Und ihr wisst, ich mache wie immer nicht lauter, weil er immer das gleiche erzählt.
Weggeschneit. Wait a minute, was ist das? Das ist Endgame DLC, das ist DLC Map. Da lassen sie sich weg, Schneiber. Alter, schreckt. Richtig hardcore schreckt hier.
Alles weg genau, scoped. 360.
Alter, die lassen sich bashen. Das ist ein cooler Clip. Ich mag generell, da gibt es leider viel zu wenig in Battlefield 3 so Offensive Sniping-Gedöns, das finde ich geil. Das ist nice, das gucke ich mir gerne an.
Zack, in your face.
Komm, und jetzt noch einmal kreisen, einmal kreisen.
Er wieder, er wieder. Er wieder. Das ist wieder so eine ganz, ganz faire Spawn-Ray-Metro-Runde. Guckt euch das mal an alle Flaggen, alles hier drüben.
Jetzt wird wieder erstmal alles, in your face.
Und jetzt noch, jetzt hat er noch einen Shotgun aufgehoben. Oh, die kriegen auf den Sack. Alter, haben die auf den Sack gekriegt.
Kranger Scheiß. Die hat er aber echt auseinander genommen jetzt. Oh, der Typ wieder. Geh weg. Der sitzt die ganze Runde rum und snipert sich einen ab und macht 3 Kills die Runde.
Okay, wenigstens sehe ich den Gegner diesmal.
Der sitzt am Arsch der Welt und macht 3 Kills die Runde. Der hat ja schon geübt, das sieht man, aber das bringt trotzdem null, null dem Runden-Win.
Was sonst? Hä? Das war schöner Battlefield 3 Netcode hier wieder. Guckt es euch an.
What the fuck? Warum ist er nicht gestorben?
Ich meine, da hat er wieviel Schuss reingehauen? 20?
15. Okay, das ist Battlefield 3. Oh, der hat ganz schön Lack, der Dude auch.
Von dem haben wir schon öfters Clip gehabt, das ist der mit dem Activate-Windows-Typ. Was ist denn das Windows 7? Ist das das Windows 7 Activate?
Windows 10? Aber Windows 10 hat doch gar keinen Activate-Overlay. Ach, ihr seht nichts? Ja, das ist nicht schlimm.
Ja, Hüft-Spray P90. Deswegen mag ich das Ding. Du kannst einfach across the map hip-firen und was killen.
Jetzt werden sie wieder weggesprayt. Nachladen, nachladen, nachladen. Und rausgehen, wegsprayen, bam, jawoll. Warum will er die jetzt unbedingt marken umso? Kann er die nicht einfach P90en?
Jawoll. M416, beste.
Jawoll. Granate. Ach nee, das war so eine typische Battlefield-3-Granate, wo der Marker nicht weg ist wieder.
Alter, die lassen sich auch wieder wegsprayen. Aber das ist so eine typische Bazaar-Geschichte. Wenn du da eine gute Pose hast, dann kannst du einfach mal 5 Minuten stehen und gerade ausschießen, wenn du killst 30 Leute.
Ach, jetzt hat er den Fehler gemacht, den hatte ich auch gemacht, nämlich reingepusht. Das wäre viel besser gewesen, einfach stehen zu bleiben. Oh, underrated map, richtig underrated map. Doch, ist es. Ist es. Ich finde, das ist eines der besten Battlefield-3-Maps. Was erzählt er denn für einen Scheiß? Anzeige ist raus.
Die haben alle so einen krassen Lag. Die hören auf zu schießen und eine halbe Minute später stirbt der Gegner.
Jawoll. Wegsprayen, so muss es sein. Oh, oh. Okay, der Typ, der war praying dead. Die sind alle praying dead.
Aber ist okay, nur so kannst du solche Clips hinkriegen. Aber richtig nicer Clip. Ah, Sellout. Sellout. Aber wir lassen ihn, wenn wir seinen Content schon gucken, lassen wir ihn eine Runde Sellout machen.
Das war der Test für die Battlefield 2042 Bots. Das ist möglich. Das kann ich mir gut vorstellen. Wenn die Bots so gut werden in 2042, dann die sind bestimmt Blockchain AI trainiert.
Wir wissen ja, ohne AI in Blockchain geht heute gar nichts mehr.
Ah, Resident Sleeper. Ah, Chet Snipes. Cool, wenn man es macht, aber so eine Spannung zu gucken ist es nicht.
Sag mal, wie fliegen die Typen eigentlich? Ist das gestellt? Ach nee, der will den Panzer bashen unten. Okay, okay. Ja, nee, nee, passt. Das ist mir gefallen.
Ja, ja. Du musst wiederbeleben. Ohne wiederbeleben hast du gelitten. Du kannst nicht 1 gegen 20 spielen. Du bist nicht konstant.
Erstmal M16 in your face, beste.
Das war ein cooler, realistischer Clip. Bashen und wiederbeleben. Das, was man als guter Medic macht oder als Assault. Bashen und wiederbeleben. So musst du es machen. Was ist das überhaupt für eine Pepega Auflösung? 800 x 600 oder was?
900 x 600.
Oh, jetzt wurde er sinnlos gehittert. Von irgendeinem Hüftspray-Support-Typ.
Er wurde weggesprüht und gebetet.
Das Spiel auf dem Laptop, ja, das kann tatsächlich sein. Da ist er wieder. Das ist keine Metro.
Also ein bisschen mehr Mühe geben, beim kommentieren, könnte er sich ja.
Oh, jawoll, jawoll, jawoll. Bashen, alter, bashen. Alter, dass der das überlebt. Guck mal, er denkt sich schon, ich bin jetzt eigentlich dead, aber die Leute kriegen es nicht gebacken. Und jetzt werden sie wiederbelebt, jetzt kann er sie wieder wegspray. Sinti, sag mal. Wie ist es nicht schenken, dass er hinter einem Stein liegt und dann auch noch an ihm vorbeirennt?
Er hat immer neue Eclipse. Jetzt? Nee.
Was für ein Ding? Alles klar.
Kommt vor.
Deswegen ist es wichtig, dass ein Surfer ordentlich amministriert und moderiert ist. Dass diese Quote von False Cheating Kicks möglichst gering ist und man auch die Cheater erwischt, die jetzt nicht gerade super krasse Stats haben. Manche halten sich ja da zurück.
Was bräuchte mal deine Hilfe? Das kommt mal kurz rein. Also was? Moment, Moment. Bräuchte mal deine Hilfe bei folgendem Problem. Wenn ich meinen PC runterfahre und acht Stunden auf Arbeit gehe, ist er, wenn ich nach Hause komme, im Logscreen Modus habe jetzt App.
Was? Ready im Bier? Du fährst den wahrscheinlich nicht runter. Der geht wahrscheinlich einfach nur Suspend to RAM oder Suspend to Disk und irgendein Event weckt ihn wieder auf, zum Beispiel Mausbewegung oder so.
Vielleicht putzt jemand deinen Schreibtisch und drückt aus Versehen den Knopf oder bewegt die Maus und der Rechner geht wieder an.
Du kannst das ausschalten. Du kannst irgendwo Edit Power Settings, Power Plan, kannst du irgendwie einstellen, was der machen soll beim runterfahren. Und da kannst du diesen Hybrid Standby-Gedöns ausschalten.
Dann fährt er auch richtig runter und geht nicht einfach so an. Der Chat ist auch wieder high IQ. Das kann man alles ausprobieren.
So, bei der Gelegenheit, ich gucke gerade noch mal in die Subs. Erstellzeitsubscribed, Dankeschön, vor 16 Monaten. Falls ihr es schon vorgelesen habt, wenn nicht, danke für den Massify IQ-Sub. Gebe es Twitch hat abonniert, Dankeschön.
Deck, weiter. Nklox, Dankeschön für den Sub. Ach, die machen AI-Blockchain Anti-Cheat, kein Problem mehr.
SIF NDE, 6 Monate, Dankeschön für den Sub. Ja, auf Kollegen, kommt zum Punkt. Kommt zum Punkt.
Ja, habe ich auch schon gesagt. Hat er recht. Wie sieht es denn bei Apex mit Cheatern aus? Ist das da schlimm oder nicht so schlimm?
Mein Cheater gibt es überall, aber Apex hat viele Cheater.
Ja, ja.
Hat er recht.
Naja, irgendwo musst du ja mal einen Strich machen.
Ja, ja.
Aber das ist persönlich für mich. Ich denke, Battlefield ist alles über diese tollen Spiele. Vielleicht sollte es eine Option sein.
Das ist persönlich für mich. Ich denke, Battlefield ist alles über diese tollen Spiele. Vielleicht sollte es eine Option sein.
In Overwatch kriegen sie es zum Beispiel ganz gut hin. Auch wenn es Cheater gibt.
Einfach das Spiel in Cobalt programmieren, dann wird es mit dem Cheaten auch schwer. Warum?
Ich weiß das nicht als Gewalt, aber was hat die Programmiersprache, die das Programmiert ist, für einen Einfluss darauf, ob man cheaten kann oder nicht?